zeichen gegen rassismus in mehreren
deutschen städten protestieren
zehntausende menschen gegen hass und
gewalt
tatort gartenlaube in
nordrhein-westfalen weg die polizei
einen neuen schweren fall von
kindesmissbrauch auf elf verdächtige
werden festgenommen
erster blick auf die korona app so soll
die warnung von kontaktpersonen
funktionieren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend ich begrüße
sie zu den heute -nachrichten auch heute
mit sport und seit langem mal wieder
norbert lehmann ganz schön guten am tor
von mir
das hat es lange nicht mehr gegeben dass
ein vorfall in den usa
der tod des schwarzen george floyd durch
weiße polizisten nicht nur im eigenen
land sondern auch in anderen ländern und
kontinenten zu solchen reaktionen führt
in amerika protestieren sie ja seit
knapp zwei wochen wir heute wieder zu
zehntausenden und auch weltweit gehen
jetzt immer mehr menschen auf die straße
sie alle wollen ein zeichen setzen gegen
rassismus in vielen deutschen städten
demonstrierten heute zehntausende unter
dem motto black lifes matt schwarze
leben zählen thomas concia berichtet
münchen schweigeminute in schwarz eine
silent demo stilles gedenken an george
floyd stille solidarität und
entschlossenheit auch in berlin
es sind 15.000 auf dem alexanderplatz
sie protestieren gegen rassismus gegen
das was es nicht nur in den usa gibt
zu sichern
ding aufgewachsen bin über allem ein tag
oder je nachdem
durchblick hill nicht sagen sie man die
gemeinderat bekommen vermisst ich dem
mega also auf ein wort halten und dass
ich halt zurück in mein land zum
beispiel nicht abends ganze mal
rausgehen und nach hause kommt ohne
angst haben dass ich als ich angehalten
werden noch mal im ausland geparkt
werden erfahrungen die niemand machen
sollte sagen demonstranten in düsseldorf
in nürnberg in stuttgart in 26 städten
28.000 anfragen listet die bundes
antidiskriminierungsstelle seit 2006
keine einzelfälle machen etwa ein
drittel unserer gesamtfälle aus das sind
fälle die diskriminierung betreffenden
aus rassistischen gründen oder wegen der
ethnischen herkunft ist bei julias ist
ein virus die botschaft auch in hamburg
gibt es vereinzelt auseinandersetzungen
mit der polizei
eine nicht mehr ganz so stille demo mehr
informationen zu den demonstrationen
finden sie auf der zdf heute app dort
finden sie auch einen eindrucksvollen
bericht aus den usa wie schwarze foto
journalistinnen und journalisten die
proteste erleben will us-präsident trump
einen großen teil der amerikanischen
soldaten aus deutschland abziehen
laut medienberichten gibt es solche
pläne im weißen haus offiziell bestätigt
sind sie nicht in deutschland zeigen
sich politiker und militärexperten
dennoch irritiert denn abgestimmt wäre
das ganze nicht david gebhard berichtet
schon als der us präsident vor
eineinhalb jahren soldaten auf dem
stützpunkt ramstein besuchte stand die
drohung im raum teil truppenabzug aus
deutschland nun soll trump laut
medienberichten ernst machen die
regierungskoalition in berlin verstimmt
ein weiter weg ruf für uns hier in
europa einfach festzustellen wir können
uns nicht mehr darauf verlassen dass die
amerikaner immer und in jeder situation
für uns da sind wir müssen unser
schicksal selbst in die hand nehmen
innerhalb von drei monaten knapp 10.000
soldaten abzuziehen
da geht es glaube ich auch einfach darum
der amerikanischen öffentlichkeit etwas
zu beweisen
die rede ist von einer reduzierung der
us truppenpräsenz in deutschland von
derzeit rund 35.000 soldaten um 9500
einen teil solle zurück in die usa
geholt werden andere verlegt etwa nach
im uhren der ministerpräsident dort
frohlockt ich habe eine tiefe hoffnung
dass aufgrund der vielen gespräche die
wir geführt haben und weil wir gezeigt
haben wie solide wir als partner in der
nato sind ein teil der heute in
deutschland stationierten soldaten
tatsächlich nach polen kommt das wird
eine verstärkung der ostflanke der nato
sein
doch experten warnen vor gravierenden
auswirkungen einer us-truppen verlegung
nach osten sollten sie wollen das hin
verlegt werden könnten noch ganz andere
probleme entstehen denn wenn sie nach
polen verlegt werden und es sind
kampftruppen
dann würde das höchstwahrscheinlich
gegen die nato russland grund akte
verstoßen die dann hinfällig wäre und
damit hätten wir eine komplett neue
sicherheitspolitische situation in
europa trump drängt deutschland seit
jahren seine militärausgaben zu erhöhen
ein teil truppenabzug von dem us medien
wissen wollen nicht aber die deutsche
bundesregierung zeigt eine weitere
abkühlung einer längst frostigen
beziehungen
schauen wir auf den us wahlkampf da hat
joe biden nach den jüngsten vorwahlen
bei den demokraten die notwendige
mehrheit für eine
präsidentschaftskandidatur hinter sich
der ehemalige vizepräsident von barack
obama wird voraussichtlich auf dem
parteitag der demokraten im august
nominiert bei der präsidentschaftswahl
am dritten november würde beiden gegen
präsident tram antreten
nach deutschland da sind ermittler
fassungslos über einen neuen großen fall
von sexuellem missbrauch an kindern
die behörden informierten heute darüber
in münster festnahmen gab es aber auch
in hessen niedersachsen und brandenburg
sechs männer und eine frau sitzen in
untersuchungshaft
ihre opfer drei jungen die heute 15 und
zwölf jahre alt sind dort der färber
berichtet die kleinen gartenlaube in
münster es wird wie eine idylle
es ist der ort des martyriums für zwei
jungen fünf und zehn jahre alt eine tat
erst vor wenigen wochen die polizei nach
ersten ermittlungen geschockt vom
ausmass vier erwachsene männer vergeben
sich an zwei kleinen jungs wechselseitig
und aufs schlimmste
es werden gegenstände benutzt
sie können sich jetzt nicht vorschnell
außenkameras innen videoüberwachte
doppelstockbetten die technik versteckt
in einer zwischendecke der
hauptverdächtige ein 27-jähriger it
spezialist hat sogar einen serverraum er
missbraucht den sohn seiner
lebensgefährtin stellt bilder davon ins
netz knüpft kontakte zu anderen tätern
ermittler stoßen auf immense datenmengen
mehr tatorte ein ganzes netz der
sexuellen gewalt gegen kinder
ein drittes opfer zwölf jahre alt selbst
die erfahrensten kriminalbeamten
sind an den grenzen des menschlichen
täglichen gestoßen
von weit darüber hinaus zu wissen dass
wir oft nur die spitze des eisbergs
sehen macht die ganze arbeit zu einer
herkulesaufgabe
der hauptverdächtige ist einschlägig
vorbestraft und er hat alle
missbrauchsbilder professionell
verschlüsselt das gilt auch für weitere
verdächtige sieben sitzen nun in haft
die auswertung wird lange dauern
schauen wir jetzt auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen danach gehen die
neuinfektionen weiter zurück im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 290 menschen neu
angesteckt insgesamt zählt die johns
hopkins universität mehr als 185.000
fälle davon gelten rund 169.000 als
genesen 8600 68 menschen sind in
verbindung mit 19 gestorben
das corona virus in schach halten dabei
soll auch eine web helfen an der schon
länger gearbeitet wird federführend sind
da die deutsche telekom und sap
beide konzerne hatten stets betont wie
wichtig ihnen dabei transparenz ist
tatsächlich wurden jetzt entscheidende
details zur app veröffentlicht andreas
gaber erklärt aber erst einmal wie die
wahren app technisch überhaupt
funktioniert über eine besondere
bluetooth funktechnik sendet die app
identifikation scouts aus die werden
ständig neu zufällig generiert
gleichzeitig horcht die app ob in einem
bestimmten umkreis andere geräte
ebenfalls solche dozenten kommen sich
zwei geräte lang genug nahe genug
tauschen sie ihre codes aus
so entsteht auf jedem gerät eine liste
mit eigenen anonymen codes und eine mit
den codes von geräten die man getroffen
hat auch anonym
beide listen bleiben zunächst lokal auf
dem gerät erst wenn ein nutzer positiv
getestet wurde
kann dieser der app erlauben
informationen an einen zentralen server
weiterzugeben
nach der methode für die sich die
bundesregierung nun entschieden hat
erhält der zentrale server nur die
eigenen codes der infizierten person
nicht aber die liste mit den codes
seiner kontakte darauf wird die liste
der eigenen codes an alle smartphones
mit der app verschickt die sucht nach
übereinstimmungen anders gesagt der
abgleich erfolgt nach diesem modell nur
lokal nur auf dem gerät der betroffenen
was heißt das alles konkret für die
anwender
was für ein coup 19 erkrankte und was
für die ämter noch im juni soll die app
ja an den start gehen sven regn hat sich
schon einmal mit ihr vertraut gemacht
so sieht sie aus die app von der sich
politik und gesundheitsbehörden so viel
versprechen
eine erste version haben die entwickler
ins netz gestellt so kann jeder
interessierte vorab schon mal sehen wie
etwa die eingabe funktioniert wenn der
nutzer positiv auf coop 19 getestet
wurde
wenn ich jetzt beim arzt gewesen bin
bekomme ich einen so genannten hand oder
ein qr-code und dann weiß die app ganz
genau okay ich bin jetzt infiziert ich
wurde positiv getestet und hat dessen
können dann halt auch andere leute
gewarnt werden nur zum spaß kann also
niemand corona alarm auf dem handy
auslösen ein echter kontakt alarm sieht
so aus also hier kann man jetzt
beispielsweise auch eine test
notification also eine testplanung quasi
ausgeben lassen und dann sehen wir wie
sie oben auch rein ploppt und da sehen
wir covern app gerade eben eine risk
notification erst die allianz von google
zuständig für alle android smartphones
und apple hat den notwendigen neuen
bluetooth kontakt standard möglich
gemacht den nutzen jetzt die
programmierer von sap und der telekom
als erste in europa wir wollen alle mal
wieder reisen und grenzen sollen
durchlässig sein und wir wollen auch
keine
putz grenze haben wir bringen dann
vorschlagen europäischer ebene ein und
der wird im moment auch sehr wohlwollend
wahrgenommen
auch die wichtigste datenschutz frage
beantwortet der blick in den
programmcode der abwehr erfährt noch
dass das system plötzlich einen
positiven kurs 19 kontakt in den
vergangenen 14 tagen meldet niemand alle
informationen sind nur auf dem handy
gespeichert nur der nutzer alleine
entscheidet also ob er diese information
an das gesundheitsamt weitergibt
heute ist der tag der organspende sind
auch der ist geprägt von corona in
deutschland warten derzeit 9000 menschen
auf eine lebensrettende transplantation
doch es gibt viel mehr bedürftige als
spender nach langer diskussion wurde
anfang des jahres ein neues gesetz
beschlossen und auch wenn es noch nicht
in kraft ist zeigt die debatte offenbar
wirkung
während sich in den usa beispielsweise
die zahl der spender in der korona krise
halbierte steigt sie in deutschland
sogar an heike kruse berichtet seit vier
jahren steht sie auf der warteliste eine
erbkrankheit zerstört die leber von anja
falkenhain aber es gibt immer noch zu
wenig spenderorgane
ich würde auch jederzeit irgendjemand
anderen ein organ spenden natürlich dass
auch irgend jemanden für mich spendet in
der hoch-zeit der korona pandemie ging
die anzahl der gespendeten organe stark
zurück in italien um 40 prozent in
spanien um 75 prozent in frankreich um
91 prozent in deutschland aber nur um 14
prozent in deutschland ist die situation
so gewesen dass auf den
intensivstationen tatsächlich noch
kapazität existiert hat um solche
patienten mit einer schweren
hirnschädigung die potenzielle
organspender sind auch zu behandeln und
auch an die organspende zu denken in den
anderen kliniken in europa ist es häufig
so gewesen dass man gar keine zeit hatte
sich darum zu kümmern
betrachtet man das gesamte erste
halbjahr nicht nur die korona hochzeit
dann ist die anzahl der gespendeten
organe bei uns sogar um vier prozent
gestiegen
ralf piepen hagen hofft dass das noch
mehr wird das thema organspende hat die
ihn vor seinem radunfall vor acht jahren
nie in
passiert in letzter minute bekam er eine
neue leber transplantiert ich weiß nicht
wer das war ich kenne nämlich kann
einfach nur sagen ja sie dankbar bin ich
habe jetzt acht jahre geschenkt gekriegt
ich nicht nochmal 30
regelmäßig kommt jetzt ein check ups in
die klinik trotz aller
vorsichtsmaßnahmen wegen corona ralf
piepen hagen genießt sein zweites leben
der korona lockdown hat in vielen teilen
der erde dazu geführt dass die natur mal
durchatmen konnte nicht so in australien
das great barrier reef im nordosten des
kontinents ist das größte korallenriff
der welt und zählt seit fast 40 jahren
zum weltnaturerbe
doch der klimawandel macht aus dem
farbenfrohen taucherparadies eine trifft
korallen wüste allen rettungsversuchen
zum trotz wie uns normen odenthal zeigt
farbenpracht das war einmal und kommt
vielleicht nie wieder korallenbleiche so
weit das auge reicht schaden den man
nicht übersehen kann und eine ursache
die sich nicht leugnen lässt sagen
wissenschaftler
die erde wird immer wärmer wir hatten in
den vergangenen monaten absolute
rekordtemperaturen am ganzen great
barrier reef es gab keine weniger heißen
flecken norden süden nirgendwo erstmals
war das ganze riff überhitzt und die
bleiche war bislang nie weitreichender
als in diesem jahr
die reparatur des riffs sie gleich der
arbeit des fonds im labor züchten
forscher mit großem aufwand korallen und
siedeln sie dann wieder an
es gibt durchaus erfolge aber die
rückschläge sind einfach zu heftig immer
kürzer die abstände zwischen den
gleichen immer kürzer die zeit der
erholung anderswo hat die korona
pandemie der umwelt eine verschnaufpause
verschafft hier nicht manche ökosysteme
haben profitiert von der abwesenheit von
menschen durch den lock down in
verschiedenen ländern
ist das nicht so die touristen sind
nicht das zentrale problem des riffs
klimawandel treibhausgase egal wo genau
sie auf der erde entstehen ein
weltnaturerbe fast so groß wie
deutschland kämpft ums überleben und hat
keine guten karten
traurig aber jetzt zur
fußball-bundesliga und zu dir norbert
und da sind ja die bayern nicht zu
bremsen allerdings ein klarer sieg der
münchner auch gegen leverkusen bayer
hatte zwar das hinspiel in münchen
gewonnen war aber heute chancenlos gegen
bärenstarke barrieren hier die
bisherigen ergebnisse des 30
spieltags leverkusen verliert also 24
leipzig lässt gegen den tabellenletzten
paderborn ganz wichtige punkte liegen
nur 11 frankfurt unterliegt mainz mit 0
2 düsseldorf und hoffenheim trennten
sich 2 2
das abendspiel dortmund gegen hertha und
bereits gestern der freiburger 1 0 sieg
gegen gladbach die tabelle bayern klar
vorne mit zehn punkten vorsprung auf
dortmund der bvb kann aber heute abend
wieder etwas aufholen
leipzig dritter gladbach vierter
leverkusen fünfter hoffenheim sechster
die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt mit
schalke und ganz unten alles unverändert
düsseldorf auf dem relegationsplatz vor
bremen und schlusslicht paderborn und
das abendspiel dortmund gegen hertha
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen um 23 uhr
im aktuellen sportstudio mit vielen
interessanten gesprächsgäste ja bei den
fußballern männern ist also der
rekordmeister aus münchen auf bestem weg
zum meisterschaft bei den fußballfrauen
ist es der serien meister aus wolfsburg
es sind keine vier minuten gespielt als
alexander popp klar macht wie das heute
läuft volle pulle für die
wolfsburgerinnen technisch anspruchsvoll
von der nationalspielerin
es folgen drei weitere tore für die
gastgeberinnen bevor dem ffc frankfurt
durch laura freigang der ehrentreffer
gelingt die partie zwischen dem tabellen
erster und vierter bleibt jedoch
einseitig svenja huth mit ihrem zweiten
treffer zum 5 2 1 endstand die
wolfsburgerinnen spazieren mit elf
punkten vorsprung entspannt dem vierten
meistertitel
in serie entgegen start des
finalturniers der basketball bundesliga
und da trafen heute nachmittag im ersten
spiel göttingen und crailsheim
aufeinander
und da gab es gleich die erste
überraschung göttingen vor der saison
berechnung tabellen-neunter besiegt den
tabellendritten aus crailsheim mit 89 zu
78 mann des spiels burtons wendet uns
mit 30 punkten und dem zweiten spiel der
gruppe a trifft heute abend der deutsche
basketball meister bayern münchen auf
vielen dank
bei uns im wetter am sonntag das bleibt
im norden und süden regnerisch in der
mitte aber wird es freundlich zu den
gemischten aussichten gleich gunther
tiersch das war's für diesen samstag
danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie um drei
viertel elf zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen wieder für 7.19 uhr
ihnen noch einen vergnügten samstagabend
[Musik]
und liebe zuschauer morgen gibt es bei
uns zwei wärter zonen mit regen und eine
mit sonnenschein das ist mäßig warm
noch hält sich die wärme bei uns zurück
genauso wie in frankreich und norden von
spanien 15 bis 20 grad etwa ganz anders
in osteuropa da haben wir die hitze 25
bis 30 grad und sie reicht bis weit in
den norden von russland das ist ziemlich
ungewöhnlich für anfang juni heute nach
gibt es dauerregen in süddeutschland der
sich vom schwarzwald an
morgen früh bis ins nördliche bayern
ausbreitet schaue auch morgen früh im
nordwesten sonst bleibt erst mal trocken
und morgen vormittag weitere schauer
dann hier im nordwesten und im emsland
zum teil und dauerregen etwa von den
alpen bis zum erzgebirge zwischendrin
scheint die sonne zeitweise das wird
auch am nachmittag zu sein
der dauerregen im südosten wird noch
etwas stärker und die schauer erreichen
die ostsee und den harz zum teil mit
gewittern und wir haben diesen starken
west bis südwestwind in norddeutschland
zumindest mit stürmischen böen
die temperaturen steigen noch ein
bisschen an gegenüber heute sind 16 bis
22 grad aber an den alpen bei dauerregen
kaum 13
und die aussichten in der neuen woche
noch leicht wechselhaft aber ab dienstag
in norddeutschland mehr sonne im süden
mehr reden ich wünschen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut